I get goosebumps even telling the story
he said you know at the point in my
career that I'm at now I can't really
expect to learn a ton from courses that
I don't already know and so what I've
decided to do is I created a learning
budget I allocate that to crazy ideas
that I give myself complete permission
to fail and what happens most times is
they do nothing he said but every once
in a while I have one that clicks and it
takes off like crazy and I innovate the
entire Marketplace again and so as soon
as I got back I cranked all the ads to
increase with this new investment amount
built into it and we scaled like even
crazier simply by reinvesting a
percentage of what we make into crazy
ideas